[Musik]
suzuki leute was geht ab und damit
können wir noch kurz wir trinken nämlich
heute während des videos ganz entspannt
noch so einen cappuccino hier ach was
das cappuccino espresso natürlich schon
besser etwas geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
da wollte ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut wir machen heute einen neuen park
von amazon gadgets wir haben wirklich
richtig neueste gadgets rausgesucht für
unter fünf euro
okay waren rede ich von mir ich bin
heute alleine juli ist leider nicht am
start weswegen die kamera steht und wir
heute zum ersten mal in 4k filmen ich
hoffe das merkt man ein bisschen genau
ich werde dann im schnitt immer für euch
hansen aber das solltest du auf jeden
fall funktionieren ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß checkt auf jeden fall auf dem
ersten part ab da gab es amazon geht
schutz für unter zehn euro
und ich würde sagen wir lieber gar nicht
lange erwartet aber bitte auch nicht zu
viel weil ich meinen wir sind hier bei
unter fünf euro das ist wirklich günstig
also hilfreiche tipps für unter fünf
euro trotzdem habe ich richtig dass ihr
zu zeigen und wir schauen uns das erste
produkt an let's go als erstes gadget
wann welcher in flaschen öffnung
vorstellen jedoch handelt es sich
hierbei nicht um einen gewöhnlichen
flaschenöffner sondern um einen der nach
dem öffnen der flasche den kronkorken
weg schießen können wir geben zu dass
dieses gadget vielleicht nicht besonders
nützlich ist da also weiß es ist nicht
nützlich da habt ihr recht aber ich habe
das noch nie gesehen habt also mit einem
flaschenöffner das raus kind wollen da
kannst du dann auf guten party also ich
kann mir schon vorstellen dass das nice
wäre aber in unseren augen sieht es
trotzdem nach einer menge spaß aus im
inneren des gadgets ist eine feder
eingebaut welche mal nach hinten ziehen
muss um den öffner zu laden wenn man nun
einen kronkorken in die dafür
vorgesehene öffnung steckt ist der
schießende flaschenöffner einsatzbereit
auf knopfdruck kann man nun den deckel
raus schießen die kronkorken können
sogar bis zu fünf meter weit fliegen der
öffner ist in den fahrten geld ja gut
die farben sind eigentlich egal
ich habe dann auf jeden fall bestellt
alle produkte sind wie immer auch in der
video
haben verlinkt das heißt wenn irgendwas
neues feld kauft das gerne über meinen
link ich kriege da ein bisschen prozent
heran
jetzt ist allerdings die aufgabe den
flaschenöffner zu finden und leute was
ich alles sagen wollte lasst mal auf
jeden fall hier ist auch schon lasst mal
sofort nein ist er nicht ein
wo ist er jetzt habe ich ihn er ist ja
ein pakt wie sie als werder-fan which
was ich noch sagen leute lasst mal super
gerne einen daumen nach oben da wenn als
nächster part am amazon geht es für
unter 100 euro kommen soll ist natürlich
dann ein bisschen teurer für mich
deswegen will ich das super gerne wissen
guck mal hier schön eingepackt kubicki
bin mal gespannt ob nämlich überzeugt
flaschenöffner kann ich sehr gut
gebrauchen auch weil ich mache
eigentlich die meisten flaschen einfach
mit einer flasche auf 8 wir haben sogar
ja es ist genau das wollte ich noch
sagen es ist nicht genau der wie im
video den gibt es leider nicht mehr
ich hab den anderen gekauft finde ich
aber noch nicht aus die ist halt auch so
aus wie sonne kann und jetzt brauchen
wir das schon eine sitzen ja schon aber
ein paar film also hier handelt es sich
um nicht alkoholische getränke natürlich
sonst muss man etwas finden was so
deckel hat die hat ein kumpel hier
vergessen und jetzt ach komm jetzt ist
es schon geladen oder wie jetzt sieht
man dass hier zurück hier bin ich jetzt
der dumme oder
achso schwäbisch alexander merz habe ich
auch von euch bekommen weil ich da
wieder etwas durcheinander gebracht man
zieht denn erst nach hinten habe ich
schon wieder vergessen anscheinend dann
macht man das auf und jetzt kann man ihn
raus verfahren
jawoll also ich muss sagen überzeugt
mich schon das werde ich jetzt nicht
trinken ist jetzt nicht mehr krass aber
die dinger sind schon gut raus also der
rote hier ist ein bisschen stärker auf
jeden fall ja lustige sketche für eine
party oder so ich weiß wenn man das
jetzt unbedingt braucht aber ist schon
geil also ist auf jeden fall jetzt mein
neuer lieblingsname öffnung wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt und das
ist folgendes letzter auftrag ihr gerne
coole t-shirts dann ist die ein t shirt
in eurer garderobe haben das auf das
geräusch der equalizer bewegung reagiert
es kann nicht nur rhythmisch zum klang
der musik leuchten sondern euch einfach
nur aufheitern wenn ihr einen film seht
oder mit freunden redet das wichtigste
ist sich nicht in der vielfalt der
modelle zu verlieren
es wird schwer sein eine entscheidung zu
treffen aber wir glauben ja muss ich
nicht weiter schauen ihr habt ja alle
schon verstanden es geht
ich glaube dieses gadget oder t shirt
wie auch immer man das nämlich ist auch
gar nicht mal so unbekannt ich habe es
natürlich bestellt irgendein modell
und das hier ist angekommen achso bevor
ich es vergesse zu sagen das ist das
einzige was wir heute haben was über
fünf euro liegt ja ich habe das
günstigste genommen ich weiß jetzt nicht
mehr ganz genau wie teuer das weiß auch
nicht irgendwie 20 euro oder so aber
aber unter 5 euro liegt das preislich
leider nicht also das funktioniert auf
jeden fall folgendermaßen hier kommen
zwei kleine batterien rein und dann ist
das verbunden hierdurch t shirt durch
mit seinem kabel und das geht dann hat
ihr zu diesem display falls man das so
nennen kann ich brauche erstmal
batterien und schon an
okay wir ziehen das nur eben an nur
irgendwas ist hier gerade noch ein
bisschen falsch da kann man ja so sieht
das jetzt aus kann man das verhindern
oder ich weiß nicht so ganz
ach so jetzt brauchen wir musik naja
moment
[Musik]
ja ich würde sagen dass reagiert
natürlich auch meine stimme weswegen wir
das jetzt einmal an lassen oder ist auch
ganz nice ich weiß nicht wer für eine
party so vielleicht auch ganz witzig
keinen plan funktioniert auf jeden fall
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt let's go das ist wirklich mega
nice hier habe ich jetzt leider so ein
amateurvideo sag ich mal gefunden
es geht halt einfach um so eine art
ventilator denen man ans handy machen
kann ja also das ist wie so ein usb
kabel kann es einfach unten rein stecken
sondern ratlos ich habe ihn mal in pink
bestellt wir haben dann auch schon
kostet glaube ja nur 93 oder so also ich
schaue jetzt mal ob sich das lohnt weil
man muss ja schon sagen so wenn es mal
warm ist so ein handy ventilator hört
sich auf jeden fall erstmal nicht
verkehrt an komm runter bringt hier
sogar direkt die beiden passenden
anschlüsse mit einmal hier fürs iphone
jedem brauche ich und hier aber auch
noch für android geräte iphone
entsperren
ok
ok und dann haben wir jetzt hier den
ventilator ja also ich muss sagen so ein
bisschen wind macht ja allerdings meiner
meinung nach viel zu wenig du musst ihn
wirklich schon laden dein gesicht halten
und da irgendwas zu spüren
hätte ich mir jetzt ein bisschen besser
vorgestellt also kannst du dich auch mal
schneller drehende oder muss ich dir
anschauen
schrott leute ohne scheiß keine ahnung
von den braucht meiner meinung nach ist
er viel zu lang da kann ja so schneller
drehen ist das denn
also da muss viel mehr power hinter
sitzen damit sich das lohnt weil sonst
ist es einfach zu schwach dort merkte
gar nicht weiter nächstes produkt das
ganze funktioniert ganz einfach sie
ziehen das magnetband in die kröte die
sie brauchen und über die zacken reißt
sich das ganze ab dann fixieren sie
sportliche situation wieder läufer trio
auf jeden fall geht es um ein
magnetisches klebeband abgehalten das
eben schon hier ist es auch sagt also
ich muss sagen die idee finde ich
wirklich mega heiß ich meine zum
beispiel meine mutter die clip auch
immer den ganzen kühlschrank voll und
ein magnetisches klebeband ist natürlich
super
das hatte jetzt leider nur nicht die
besten amazon rezensionen aber wir
probieren das einfach mal aus sagt ich
weiß jetzt mal ein stück ab irgendwie
also diese hülle hier oder wie man das
nennt ist ein bisschen schlecht
verarbeitet das glaubt die bricht
ziemlich schnell aber an sich gc jungen
die rolle das hier ist ein sehr
wichtiger brief da klebe ich das jetzt
einfach mal hinten drauf wo
normalerweise könnte man das jetzt einen
kühlschrank heften probiere ich dass
meine leute das problem ist halt einfach
dieses magnetband ist nicht stark genug
ich habe jetzt extra schon zwei streifen
benutzt und wenn wir das hier dran
bleibt also es hält halten nicht so
wirklich ne also man muss halt leider
ziemlich viele streifen benutzen damit
das hält bisschen schade aber so
funktioniert es auf jeden fall ja heute
weiter geht's nächstes produkt als
nächstes wollen wir euch das toiletten
nicht vorstellen
dieses ermöglicht euch dass euer klo in
verschiedenen farben beleuchtet wird
angetrieben wird die led durch drei
aaa-batterien leider sind die batterien
aber nicht im lieferumfang enthalten
da man das gadget einfach an die
schüssel hängt ist die beleuchtung mit
jedem pc kompatibel
das budget sieht aber nicht nur echt
cool aus sondern hat auch noch einen
nutzen leute ich habe das auf jeden fall
mit reingenommen weil ich das gadget
eigentlich wir hatten das längere zeit
hier bei uns im bad ich hatte das glaube
ich schon mal in einem busch video drin
ich bin mit hat mich sicher jemand
kurzer auszug davon und jetzt machen wir
direkt weiter in bad und zwar mit diesem
chlor led da bin ich jetzt werde ich mal
gespannt ob das funktionieren kann hat
immer nur das klima jetzt hier dran
und jetzt muss ich eigentlich dass ihr
uns runter machen und jetzt abziehen und
dann müsste es ja keine spürbaren
einfach falsch und hat mal besser
genutzt so machen als bewegungsmelders
wir uns hier den markt ist vielleicht
schlauer
guck mal so weil er gestern so ein
schild wissen jetzt hier raus weißt du
ja so ein bewegungsmelder dran das heißt
wenn du auf chlor ist leuchtet halt dann
klo in irgendwelchen led farben ich habe
das schon gefeiert allerdings ist schon
ein bisschen komisch und ich wollte euch
wenigstens einmal kurz gezeigt haben und
wir kommen zum nächsten produkt
ach so ich glaube ja das ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich eher was für die frauen
ich weiß gar nicht ob wir hier ein video
voller hatten oder ob ich das einfach so
gefunden habt wir haben hier das ist an
sich also wirklich gar nicht schlecht
wenn man wenig stauraum hat für schuhe
ist das eher ein schuh stapler
man hat zwei verschiedene paar schuhe
und du kannst es hier versteckt das sind
sogar 221 dann kann man das hier
vorstellen und einen schuh kommt
obendrauf einen schub kommt unten raus
wir haben zum beispiel unsere ganzen
schule jetzt dastehen und es sie schon
ziemlich zusammengepresst aus muss ich
sagen
deswegen ist es so eigentlich gar nicht
mal verkehrt
was mir an was ist das also das ist
super simpel aber gefällt mir eigentlich
und es sieht auch kummer sieht stylisch
aus kann sein ganzes zimmer mit
vorstellen also ich weiß nicht ob man
das jetzt unbedingt braucht aber kann
ich nichts gegen sagen also feiere ich
na ja also ich hoffe ich habe auch nicht
zu viel versprochen wie gesagt sind
alles gadgets für unter fünf euro
ziemlich günstig deswegen ist das jetzt
auch nicht so krass ich freue mich auf
das video gadgets für unter 100 euro das
wird auf jeden fall sehr nice und ich
würde sagen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lassen nach oben da wie gesagt
alle produkte in der beschreibung
verlinkt und wir sehen uns donnerstag
oder mittwoch wieder mit dem neuen
coolen video ich hoffe natürlich auch
der look vom video und alles was ein
bisschen anders ist als sonst habe ich
auch gefallen kann da super gerne eure
meinung in die kommentare schreiben
fragen wie man selbst war
wir sehen uns haut rein instagram alex w
checkt auch mein zwei kameras oder
meinen anderen kanal alex frei da gibt's
jeden tag ein neues reaction haut rein